yo vaivén continúa revirtiendo las duras
políticas migratorias de su antecesor el
presidente firma una nueva serie de
órdenes ejecutivas destinadas a reparar
el daño de la administración trump entre
ellas una para reunir a los casi 1000
niños que fueron separados de sus padres
en la frontera sur bajo la política de
'tolerancia cero' a la migración ilegal
del ex líder republicano jon queremos
poner en marcha un proceso de
inmigración aquí que sea humano que sea
moral que considere solicitudes de
refugiados solicitudes para que las
personas entren a este país por la
frontera de una manera que trate a las
personas como seres humanos tweets
pivotes yemen links y otra para revisar
una serie de políticas de la hera trump
como el procesamiento de solicitudes de
asilo además de una revisión general al
sistema migratorio para garantizar que
funcione correctamente
los críticos de baire manifestaron su
miedo a que la reforma migratoria
provocará un efecto llamada de migrantes
especialmente desde centroamérica pero
la administración del demócrata ha
advertido que los cambios tomarán tiempo
este no es el momento de venir a eeuu
necesitamos tiempo para implementar
un proceso de inmigración para que las
personas puedan ser tratadas con
humanidad misma
estas nuevas órdenes pasan a engrosar el
voluminoso paquete de medidas
migratorias implementadas por la
administración by de entre las que se
encuentran poner fin a la construcción
del muro fronterizo con méxico y
proteger a los llamados dreamers jóvenes
indocumentados que llegaron ilegalmente
a territorio estadounidense cuando eran
niños